MALE SPEAKER: Hello
and welcome, everyone.
Our speaker for
today is Jason Zweig.
Jason writes a weekly column,
"The Intelligent Investor,"
for the "Wall Street Journal."
It's a very, very
popular column.
He's also going to be speaking
about this book, "The Devil's
Financial Dictionary."
So I'm not going to give
away more on the subject
of that book, though.
But it's very interesting.
If you look at the
array of subjects
that Jason has written about
over the last 30 years,
he's written "The Little Book
of Safe Money-- an Investing
Guide."
He's also assisted the Nobel
Prize-winning psychologist
Daniel Kahneman in writing his
book "Thinking Fast and Slow."
Daniel Kahneman, for
those of you that know
gave a fantastic talk
at Google some time ago.
And Jason frequently speaks
to CFAs, investors, students,
journalists.
So in talking to him before the
talk, I was asking him, hey,
when did you get your CFA?
And he said, I don't have one.
And I said, do you have a CFP?
He said no.
And I said, well, at least
tell me you have an MBA.
And he said no.
And I found that
pretty interesting.
And I guess he might talk more
about why or why not that is
a good or bad thing.
Jason is guided largely
by a saying of his
father's-- it's remarkable how
much you have to learn in order
to realize how little
you need to know.
It also brings to mind what
Einstein said when he mentioned
education is what remains
after one has forgotten
what one learned in school.
So without further ado,
ladies and gentlemen,
please join me in
welcoming Jason Zweig.
JASON ZWEIG: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE].
And it's my pleasure to be here.
Like, I think, everyone
who writes and researches
for a living, Google has
been an enormous help to me
over the years.
So I think turnabout
is fair play.
I'll try to give you
some useful ideas today.
And of course for the folks
who might be tuning in
later on YouTube, welcome to all
of you, and thanks to everybody
for coming today.
So I'm going to talk
about my new book,
"The Devil's
Financial Dictionary,"
but I'll also talk a little
bit at the end about my role
in editing the Benjamin
Graham book, "The Intelligent
Investor"."
And as many of you know,
Graham was probably
the greatest investment
adviser of the 20th century,
the founder of the modern
discipline of security
analysis, Warren
Buffett's teacher.
And it was certainly
one of the great honors
I've had in my
career, to be involved
in editing his book, "The
Intelligent Investor."
So this is "The Devil's
Financial Dictionary,"
and it was inspired very
directly by "The Devil's
Dictionary" by Ambrose Bierce.
And thank you, Google
Books, if we have anybody
from Google Books in the room.
This is the title page.
The book first appeared in its
final form over a century ago.
And many people would
regard it as one
of the funniest
books ever written
in the English language.
I'm among them.
And this is Bierce.
He was born in 1842.
He is believed to
have died in 1914,
although no one
really knows for sure.
He is believed to have died
when, weary of human folly,
he walked across the border into
the Mexican Revolution hoping
that he would be shot.
And no one really knows what
happened to him after that.
But he did not
suffer fools gladly.
And here are a few
examples of definitions
from the original
"Devil's Dictionary."
This is probably his
best known definition.
Those of you who are
married-- [INAUDIBLE],
perhaps you can
sympathize with this.
Love, noun-- a temporary
insanity curable by marriage.
Another favorite of mine--
once you are in love,
you should remember this.
Jealous, adjective--
unduly concerned
about the preservation
of that which
can be lost only if it
is not worth keeping.
Here's one of his few financial
definitions that's quite good.
Finance, noun--
the art or science
of managing revenues and
resources for the best
advantage of the manager.
And I've included this one.
It gives you a sense of how dark
Bierce's view of the world was.
I don't really
endorse his pessimism.
You can draw your
own conclusions
about his personality.
But I put it up
because those of you
who buy "The Devil's Financial
Dictionary" will encounter
some definitions that I've
written that also feature
these little-- I
call them flights
of fancy, in which an
imaginary character helps
us understand a definition.
And in this case, Bierce is
giving two lines of poetry
from a non-existent
medieval English poet
named [? Bori ?] the Bald.
But in any case, so why did
I want to write this book?
Well, some of you might be
familiar with the 19th century
British essayist and historian
Thomas Carlyle, who is today
perhaps best known for
saying that economics
is the dismal science,
which is a little quip
that he made in an article he
wrote, I believe, in the 1840s.
And what I would argue after
almost 30 years of writing
about investing is
that if economics
is the dismal science, then
investing is the abysmal art.
It is rendered boring
and overly complicated.
A few words I've heard over the
years about various investing
books are some of these.
I'm sure anyone in this room
who's read a book on investing
might have adjectives of your
own you would tend to apply.
But it's never really
been clear to me
why there's no sense
of fun involved
when we talk about
investing, and also
why so few people point
out the ridiculousness
and the absurdity that often
is involved when people manage
other people's money.
So that's some of the spirit I
wanted to get at in the book.
And the other thing
is it occurred to me
as I was thinking
about recapturing some
of the spirit of Ambrose
Bierce that maybe
if you can make people laugh,
you can help them learn.
And I think one of
the real pitfalls
of traditional
financial advice is
it's so somber and
deadly serious, and sort
of self-referential, and
often self-righteous.
And one of the things I've
learned over the years
is that yes, it's true.
In the very long run,
financial markets and returns
on investments-- they're
driven by economics,
the fundamental forces
of supply demand.
But in the short-term,
the medium-term,
even the fairly long-term for
many years on end-- 3 to 5,
sometimes 10 years-- markets
are driven by psychology--
often crowd psychology,
sometimes abnormal psychology.
And another wonderful thing that
a satirical dictionary format
enables a writer to do
is to look at etymology,
the derivations of words.
Because often one of
the things we pick up
when we learn where
words come from
is the hidden meanings that lurk
within the heart of terminology
we use every day without
really being very aware of it.
One simple classic
example is-- and I'll
ask, does anybody in the room
know what do the words happy,
happen, and perhaps
all have in common?
Does anyone know
what the root word
"hap" means in early English?
AUDIENCE: Chance.
JASON ZWEIG: Exactly.
Means luck.
So remember the next
time you're happy, which
I hope will be in
a couple minutes
from now, remember that you're
happy because you're lucky,
and to some extent, to
be lucky is to be happy.
So I wanted to have some
fun with ideas like that.
But it's also I wanted to
bring in financial history
because one of the critical
things investors need to do
is learn from mistakes.
Now, we can learn
from our own mistakes,
but it's a lot cheaper to learn
from other people's mistakes,
right?
And a really simple, useful
definition of history
is it's the record of
other people's mistakes,
and also their regrets.
So we can learn from that.
And then the final
thing that I think
satire is useful for is to
fight confirmation bias.
To prevent us from
digging ourselves
into an ever deeper hole
of our own decisions,
and just constantly
drilling down
to prove that what we've
already done is right,
and just to sink into this
sinkhole of our own sunk costs
until we can't get out.
And if you can bring
a little sense of play
and make a little bit of
fun of people's ideas,
maybe you can jolt them
out of that complacency.
That at least was my hope.
So I'm just putting up one
illustration from the book
just to give you a
sense of the feel
that the publisher and
I wanted to get across.
Some you may recognize this is
a 16th century Dutch engraving
taken from a painting by the
great Dutch master Pieter
Brueghel the Elder.
And this was
engraved around 1558.
And the queenly character
sitting in the middle
is Avarizia, or greed.
And you can see
all of these people
and creatures are
worshipping her, serving her
in one form or another,
filling her chest with gold.
Her lap is full of gold.
There's a frog in
the foreground,
or it might be a toad.
Frogs and toads were symbols
of greed in medieval Europe.
And there are all kinds
of other things going on.
And at the risk of
bothering people
who are eating their
lunch, I'll point out
that on the far
right, a stork is
feeding from the bottom of that
figure immediately to the left.
And so I wanted
to give you a few
of the definitions
in the book just
to give you a feel for
what I'm trying to do.
And those of you who are in
the market for financial advice
should probably keep
these first two in mind.
So big producer, noun-- a
stock broker or insurance agent
who produces big commissions.
The term is erroneous, however.
The broker or agent doesn't
produce the commissions.
It is his clients
who produce them.
He just collects them.
So then financial
advisor-- often
someone who cares deeply
about being prudent, diligent,
competent, and
honest, in which case
his or her services
will be priceless.
Sometimes, someone
who cares only
about being a big
producer, in which case
you are in for big trouble.
This is one of my
favorite definitions.
It's very short.
Potential conflict of interest,
noun-- an actual conflict
of interest.
Every prospectus you
read, every document
your financial advisor
might hand you,
will mention this term,
potential conflict of interest.
And you should remember
that the real meaning
is actual conflict of interest.
Forecasting, noun-- the attempt
to predict the unknowable
by measuring the irrelevant.
A task that in
one way or another
employs most people
on Wall Street.
Because the human mind
hates admitting the truth
that the world is largely
random and unpredictable,
forecasters will
always be in demand
regardless of their futility.
Wall Street follows what
marketing Professor J. Scott
Armstrong has called
the seer-sucker theory.
For every seer,
there is a sucker.
In the real world, as
with weather forecasts
or predictions about who
will win a sporting event,
those making the
projections typically
estimate the likelihood
that they are correct.
Wall Street forecasts,
on the other hand,
almost never have
probabilities attached.
As decision scientist Baruch
Fischhoff wrote in 1994,
when both forecaster
and client exaggerate
the quality of
forecasts, the client
will often win the
race to the poorhouse.
And long-term is another
favorite of mine,
and I think it's one that's
very useful for people
to bear in mind.
Long-term, adjective--
on Wall Street, a phrase
used to describe a period that
begins approximately 30 seconds
from now and ends at most
a few weeks from now.
Now, here I've put up one
of my favorite images.
This is a clay model
of the liver of a sheep
from ancient Babylonia.
It was made sometime
between 1900 and 1600 BC,
so it's well over
3,500 years old.
Almost 4,000 years old.
And here's the definition.
Baru, noun-- in
ancient Mesopotamia,
a priest who specialized
in predicting the future
by studying the contours
of a liver or lung taken
from a sacrificed sheep.
The baru worked from
an intricate template,
often rendered as
the clay map, that
charted dozens of variations
on the surface of the sheep's
organ, as in this example
from the British Museum.
We may safely presume that when
the baru's predictions didn't
come true, he blamed
it on the dead sheep.
The modern version of
a Mesopotamian baru
is known as a technical analyst.
This is another
illustration that I love.
This is from a 15th
century British manuscript.
And it might look a
little mysterious to you,
but I think you'll understand
when I read the definition.
Bonasus, noun-- a
mythical creature
described by the ancient
Romans, and often included
in medieval bestiaries,
the bonasus closely
resembles a bull
but with its horns
curled back toward its tail.
Because the horns are only for
show, as the Roman naturalist
Pliny wrote, the bonasus has
no way to deter predators
and will run away as
soon as it is threatened.
When it becomes
panic-stricken, the bonasus
spews immense quantities of
flaming hot manure in its wake.
As the next stock
market crash will show,
the typical investor who
believes himself to be a bull
will turn out to be a bonasus.
Do not stand too
close behind him.
Irrational,
adjective-- a word you
use to describe any investor
other than yourself.
So here I have a little set of
some of the behavioral finance
definitions in the book.
They form a little bit of a
theme, as you might imagine.
Overconfidence-- a belief
unjustified by the evidence
that one knows more or
is better than others.
The predominant
personality trait
of most investors and
nearly every amateur trader.
To be overconfident is to be
ignorant of your own ignorance.
In the financial markets,
overcoming overconfidence
is essential and
extremely expensive.
Bull, noun-- a person who
believes that an asset will
go up in price.
A belief often based
exclusively on the fact
that the person
happens to own it.
A bull in full stomp is
almost incapable of absorbing
any evidence suggesting that
the asset might go down instead.
Bull market, noun-- a
period of rising prices that
leads many investors to
believe that their IQ has
risen at least as
much as the market
value of their portfolios.
After the inevitable
fall in prices,
they will learn that both
increases were temporary.
And this one is very
important, and we'll
circle back to this when
I talk about Benjamin
Graham toward the end.
Career risk, noun-- the risk
that by thinking independently,
a money manager might lose
clients endanger a big salary,
and harm his or her career.
For money managers, the
only risk that matters.
When professional investors
are right, no one will ask why.
Their clients will be too
busy counting their profits
to seek an explanation.
But when money
managers are wrong,
their clients will
immediately want
to know why they
made the mistake.
Portfolio managers can either be
wrong in a crowd, in which case
no one will blame them for
making the same mistake
everybody else made, or wrong
and alone, in which case
they will look like idiots.
Option, noun-- sorry,
hang on one second.
Like everything in life, this is
a little harder than it looks.
Option, noun-- the
right to buy or sell
a financial asset
at a fixed price
on or before a specific time.
From the Latin optio-- I choose.
A boon for stockbrokers
whose clients
don't understand
how options work,
and generate a fortune
in commissions as they
attempt to learn.
And here I have a
little flight of fancy.
Explain [INAUDIBLE] asking me,
a client of the brokerage firm
born rich, and how?
I put two children through
Harvard by trading options.
Unfortunately, they were
my broker's children.
Perhaps the earliest
recorded options
trade according to
Aristotle was made
by Thales of Miletus
circa 624 to 547
BC, one of the seven
sages of Greece
who put down deposits on all
nearby olive oil presses one
winter when his knowledge
of astronomy purportedly
told him that the next year
would bring a good olive crop.
Thales paid almost
nothing and profited
hugely when the
abundant harvest created
high demand for
presses, thus making
him one of the first
individual investors
to make more money trading
options than his brokers did.
He was also one of the last.
Now, obviously I have to
remind all the Googlers
that this refers to exchange
traded options rather
than incentive options.
Broker-- the comparative
form of broke.
Also, used as a noun, a
person who buys and sells
stocks, bonds, mutual funds,
and other assets for people
who are under the delusion that
the broker is doing something
other than guesswork.
One early definition
of a broker sometimes
attributed to the
British lexicographer
Samuel Johnson is a negotiator
between two parties who
contrives to cheat both.
And here I'd like to show you
this wonderful, although maybe
not so tasteful, engraving
from 1720 which illustrates
the South Sea Bubble and the
various other speculations that
swept through
Europe at that time.
And these are two brokers who
are distributing securities.
And you can see that hostility
to the financial industry
is not exactly a
contemporary phenomenon.
This is almost 400 years ago.
Panic, noun and
verb-- contagious
fear that sweeps across a
crowd, a market, or a planet,
frightening multitudes of
people into selling and leaving
the rest wondering
whether they should.
Like swarms of cicadas long ago,
there were panics roughly every
17 years-- in 1819, 1837,
1857, 1973, 1893, and 1907.
The word derives
from the god Pan,
who haunted the pastors and
wild places of ancient Greece.
In the form of a grinning but
ugly man with the horns, ears,
and hairy legs of
a goat, Pan was
the god of herds and flocks,
serenading them with his pipes.
Fittingly, Pan was
the son of Hermes,
the god of shepherds,
messengers, diplomacy, travel,
trade, and thievery, suggesting
that the relationship
between panic and trade is
as old as commerce itself.
And this illustration
comes from September 1873,
immediately after
the panic of 1873
that swept through Wall Street.
And the caption is "Panic
as a health officer
sweeping the garbage
out of Wall Street."
New York, only a
few years earlier,
had been subject to several
cholera epidemics that
were believed to have been
caused, very likely correctly,
by the abundance of
garbage in the streets,
including horse manure
and other things.
And so sanitation workers
were organized and hired
by the city, and these sweeping
crews would go through.
But here what the artist
has done very cleverly
is he's transformed one of
them into the Greek god Pan
to symbolize the financial
panic that had just struck.
Risk, noun-- the
chance that you don't
know what you are doing
when you think you do.
The prerequisite for
losing more money
in a shorter period
of time than you
could ever have
imagined possible.
Risk can be formally
defined as the odds
of an adverse or
undesirable outcome.
When the forecast is for
an 80% chance of sunshine,
for example, then the
risk of rain is 20%.
Or as the extent to
which extreme outcomes
differ from the average.
It has been
philosophically defined
by finance professor Elroy
Dimson of London Business
School this way-- risk
means more things can
happen than will happen.
In the end, risk is the gap
between what investors think
they know and what
they end up learning
about their investments,
about the financial markets,
and about themselves.
Stock, noun-- the right to
own a fraction of a business,
regarded by most investors as
the right to play a video game.
So that gives you
a taste, I think,
of some of the definitions
I have in the book,
and how I hope using a
little bit of a forked tongue
might help shock people out of
accepting things at face value
when they're dealing with
the financial markets.
And here, just getting back to
the idea of disconfirmation,
are a couple of quotes from
Warren Buffett and his business
partner Charlie Munger
about Charles Darwin.
And I think the main thing I
learned in working on this book
is how hard it is
to mock an idea
and to poke fun at it
fairly if you don't
know what you're talking about.
In order to hit the
target and to find
the humor or the
absurdity that's
lurking at the heart of an
idea or a marketing pitch
or any other investing concept
you might be confronted with,
you have to understand
it pretty well.
Because if you poke fun at it
without fully understanding it,
it just comes across as mean.
And so far, in the 3 months
this book has been out,
I haven't had anybody on
Wall Street complain to me
that I was unfair.
In fact, a lot of investment
bankers and fund managers
have said to me, oh,
you were way too nice.
So I think there's an
important lesson in this, which
is it can be quite
useful for you
as individuals and maybe as
members of an organization
before you commit to an idea,
an investment, a project,
or a significant
new initiative, it
might be worth privately seeing
if you can ridicule it first.
What's funny about it?
What makes no sense?
And I think that can be
a useful mental exercise.
Obviously I would run that
passed my supervisor before I
tried it if I were
you, but I think
there's a lot of
wisdom that can come
from trying to find the
absurdity, the humor that's
lurking inside an idea.
Believe me, it's much better to
do it in advance, before hand,
than to find out after
the fact that what we just
spent all our time and
money on was ridiculous.
So let me talk for a few
minutes about "The Intelligent
Investor."
In 2003 I had the great
honor of editing the book,
and I learned a great
deal from doing that.
Benjamin Graham
was born in 1894.
He died in 1976.
He was one of the most
successful investors
of the 20th century.
And interestingly, he
spent a great deal of time
in the first edition of the
book on this question-- what
makes an intelligent investor?
And he took great
pains to emphasize
that it's not the
kind of intelligence
that we might normally associate
with intelligence measures.
It has nothing to
do with IQ or SAT
scores or GREs or any
other standardized test.
It also doesn't have anything
to do with credentials.
And he was very
specific what he meant.
As he put it, it's
a function more
of character than intelligence,
as most people define it.
And he also, throughout
his writings,
enables us to see what
he meant by character.
What makes that kind
of intelligence?
And these are critical
virtues for anybody
who wants to succeed
as an investor,
regardless of what
investing approach you take.
So you have to be patient.
You have to be prudent.
It's very important to be
independent and skeptical.
That's at the heart
of everything.
You have to be curious
and eager to learn.
That one, at least, has
stood me in good stead.
You don't have to
be disciplined,
and that really
means self-control.
So Graham drew a key
distinction between investment
and speculation.
This paragraph I think every
investor should memorize.
An investment operation is one
which upon thorough analysis
promises safety of principal
and an adequate return.
Operations not meeting these
requirements are speculative.
And then he defines
each of these terms.
Thorough analysis--
the study of the facts
in the light of established
standards of safety and value.
So you have to work at it.
Safety of principal--
protection against loss
under all normal or
reasonably likely
conditions or variations.
And here I want to
emphasize he's not
saying that the asset you're
analyzing can't lose money.
What he's saying
is you should be
very confident based on
evidence that the business
risk is minimal.
That you're not buying into a
company or a market or an asset
class that will simply go away.
You're not going to lose
90% of your money or more
because you didn't foresee an
obvious flaw in the business
model or in the valuation.
And a really simple
example from the headlines
of the past few months would
be Valiant Pharmaceuticals,
which really built its business
on the idea of acquiring one
drug company after another and
then drastically raising prices
immediately after
the acquisition,
which any number of
people said probably
isn't a sustainable
business model.
And, at least based on what
we've seen in recent weeks,
that seems to have
been borne out.
And this is the most fascinating
part of Graham's definition
of all, I think.
What does he mean by adequate?
Or he sometimes used the
term satisfactory return.
Any rate or amount of
return, however low,
which the investor
is willing to accept
provided he acts with
reasonable intelligence.
So what he's really saying
is when you are investing,
you should ask yourself what
is the minimal rate of return
I'm willing to accept to
enter into this investment?
And that's a very helpful
way of steering people away
from having unrealistic
expectations,
which is so often a problem.
So Graham drew another
really helpful distinction
that I think is
often overlooked.
He talked about two
kinds of investors--
defensive and enterprising.
And the conventional
definition of investor-- I
think we've all heard it.
Many of you have probably
taken questionnaires
that financial advisors
give you asking
you how much risk you want
to take or you can take.
And often it breaks down
into these three categories
that I regard as kind of
silly, actually-- conservative,
moderate, and aggressive.
The notion that there are 100
million investors in the United
States, and only three
types seems a little silly.
And there's a much
more basic problem,
which is that it's
extraordinarily difficult
to measure individual
risk tolerance
before the risk
comes home to roost.
Many of you may have taken a
risk tolerance questionnaire
that asks you if the stock
market went down 20%,
what would you do?
Would you stay put?
Would you buy more?
Would you sell?
I see people nodding.
The problem is until
it goes down 20%,
everyone says, oh
yeah, I'd buy more.
Then it goes down 20% and
people sit on their hands,
or it goes down 50% and they
sell, or it goes down 80%
and they don't buy
another stock for 20 years
even though this risk
tolerance questionnaire said
they had plenty of tolerance.
So Graham instead draws
a completely different
distinction, and it
has nothing to do
with appetite for
risk or the capacity
to take risk or withstand it.
It's how hard you're
willing to work.
How interested are you?
Presumably everyone in this room
and most of the people watching
online are interested
enough in investing
to spend a few minutes
listening to a talk.
So you are probably
enterprising, or at least
tilting in that direction.
And so Graham says,
if you're defensive,
what you're trying to do
is avoid big mistakes.
And, very importantly, you don't
want to work very hard at it.
You don't want to spend
your Saturday afternoon
reading 10-Ks or downloading
financial documents
from the SEC website.
And that's fine.
If you are enterprising,
then you're
probably willing to
commit a lot of effort
to investing as an enterprise.
That's why he chose that word.
Because it is an enterprise,
it's an operation,
Graham called it.
An operation.
It's work.
And for people who enjoy
it, it's a lot of fun.
It's enormously challenging.
The critical
observation here is it
doesn't matter whether you're
defensive or enterprising.
What matters is that you
know which one you are.
If you are defensive but you
think you're enterprising,
you're going to be very sorry.
If you're enterprising and
you think you're defensive,
you'll be disappointed
because you
won't have done as well as
you could in bull markets,
and you probably will be
disappointed in bear markets,
as well.
So for people who are
defensive, a simple portfolio
of index funds that you
never touch and never trade
is perfect-- totally
defensible decision.
If you're enterprising,
that one's
not going to be very satisfying.
And the virtue of all of this
is unlike the conventional way
of separating investors,
this is very easy to measure.
Everyone intuitively
knows how interested am I
in investing as a process?
So another very
powerful idea for Graham
is the margin of safety,
and I'll summarize it
in a very simple
way, which is just
this-- that most people,
most individual investors,
ask themselves, how much money
will I make when I'm right?
And particularly among men, this
is a very standard question.
Now, on Graham's terms,
the intelligent investor
instead will ask, or
in addition will also
ask, how much money will
I lose if I'm wrong?
That forces you to focus
on your margin of safety.
Then just a couple of
quick distinctions here.
So all of us in this room
are individual investors.
Most people watching
online are also.
And we've been told
for our entire lives
that we can't compete with big
institutions like mutual funds
and hedge funds and pension
plans, insurance companies,
banks, all the other
professional investors
with millions of dollars worth
of research and resources,
high frequency trading
platforms unavailable to us.
And there is a calendar
ideology that you often hear,
which is individual
investors can
beat the pros at their
own game if you just
are faster and smarter.
And you heard this
a lot in the 1990s.
It's been cropping up
a lot again lately.
But I would ask an entirely
different question,
which is why would you
want to play that game?
The pros can't
even win that game.
Every year, typically, 70%, 80%
of all professional investors
under-perform the market.
So why would I want to play
the game that they don't even
know how to win?
Wouldn't it make more sense
for me to play my game?
And one of the reasons it's so
hard for professional investors
to win is because of the
way victory is defined.
So they have to
measure success by how
they do relative to a market
benchmark like the S&P 500.
And, short-term, how are
they doing year to date?
Over the past 12 months?
6 months?
3 months?
1 month?
Week?
Often, many of them measure
their results daily.
And that leads to an
obsession with the short-term,
and a complete myopia
for the long-term.
But how would individual
investors-- how can you,
how should you measure success?
It seems pretty
obvious to me, instead
of measuring your success
relative to the S&P
500-- who cares, right?
And instead of measuring
it short-term, just
measure it against what
you're trying to achieve,
which probably isn't beating
the S&P 500, and certainly
isn't beating it over the
past 60 days or 60 minutes.
Many of you have probably read
the wonderful Richard Feynman
book "What Do You Care
What Other People Think?",
which I love.
But I also love the
title of the book.
This is such a helpful reminder.
Why would I care whether
I'm beating the market?
That doesn't make
me richer or poorer.
If I want to match the
market, I can do it
for almost free
with an index fund.
Maybe I have other goals.
But certainly
measuring my success
by what other people
are doing is not
something I'm
interested in, and I
don't think anybody should be.
And one of the critical
advantages for individuals
is how long your time
horizon can and should be.
I mean, many of you are young.
You're in your 20s, your 30s.
Those decades are
well behind me,
but I measure my time
horizon in centuries.
I often say I'm investing
for the next 100 years
because I have children, I
have causes I care about,
and I'm not going to be able
to build the long-term legacy
with my family's wealth if
I focus on what's happening
today, this hour, this minute.
So here are two wonderful
things that Graham said.
This is from "The
Intelligent Investor,"
and it's so important,
I will read it out loud.
"But note this important fact.
The true investor scarcely ever
is forced to sell his shares.
And at all other times,
he's free to disregard
the current price quotation.
He need pay attention to it and
act upon it only to the extent
that it suits his
book, and no more."
And by suits his book, Graham
is using an old fashioned Wall
Street term for your
interim profits and losses.
"Thus,"-- and I highlighted
this in red-- "Thus,
the investor who permits himself
to be stampeded or unduly
worried by unjustified market
declines in his holdings is
perversely transforming his
basic advantage into a basic
disadvantage.
That man--" and of course
Graham was writing in the 70s,
and we could say, "that
investor would be better off
if his or her stocks had
no market quotation at all,
for the investor
would then be spared
the mental anguish caused
him by other persons'
mistakes of judgment."
And Graham often used
the term quotational loss
to describe what
happens when there's
an interim decline
in the market.
So think about what
he's saying here.
What's he's saying is that
as an individual rather than
an institution, you have
this massive advantage of not
needing to care about
what the market is
doing in the short-term.
And if you do care, you have
taken your biggest advantage
over the institutions
and turned it
into a crippling disadvantage,
because what you've done
is you've shifted
yourself from playing
your own game on your
own playing field
or pitch to playing their
game, which they can't win,
and you surely can't
win because you don't
have the resources they do.
Not that it would
help them win, either.
So then Graham
said later in 1974,
"We have heard many complaints
that institutional dominance
of the stock market has
put the small investor
at a disadvantage
because he can't compete.
The facts are
quite the opposite.
I am convinced that
an individual investor
with sound principles
and soundly
advised can do distinctly
better over the long pull
than a large institution.
Where the trust company"--
which, of course,
today we would think of as a
mutual fund company or maybe
a broker or an investment
bank-- "may have to combine its
operations to 300
concerns or less"--
the biggest companies in
the country or the world--
"the individual has up to 3,000
issues for his investigations
and choice.
Most true bargains are not
available in large blocks.
By this very fact,
the institutions
are well-nigh eliminated
as competitors
of the bargain hunter."
So what he's really
saying is not only
can individuals do well
competing against institutions,
but there's some
reason to believe
if your head is in
the right place,
you could do even better.
So what do I take
away from all of this?
The first is just to emphasize
the point Graham was just
making, which is you need
to position yourself.
If you are an enterprising
investor, you need to ask,
where can I go where the
big institutions can't?
And one obvious
choice would be stocks
that are smaller than average.
Another would be, just for
lack of a complex term,
stinker stocks-- companies
that have done terribly lately,
that professional
investors are throwing out
of their portfolios.
They're throwing them
overboard as fast as they can,
creating value for the future.
Stocks that are
hard to understand.
You may, as engineers or
quantitatively inclined people,
be able to fight your way
through prospectus better
than a lot of
professional investors.
Another way to be intelligent is
to be patient, extend your time
horizon years and
decades, as I mentioned.
Be independent.
And there's a wonderful
passage from Graham--
"You are neither right nor wrong
because the crowd disagrees
with you.
You are right because your data
and your reasoning are right."
One of Warren Buffett's favorite
passages for good reason.
And then there is
a wonderful saying
from Ralph Waldo Emerson,
the essayist and philosopher,
that I love.
"It is easy in the world to
live after the world's opinion.
It is easy in solitude
to live after our own.
But the great man,"-- the great
investor-- "is the one who,
in the midst of the crowd,
keeps with perfect sweetness
the independence of solitude."
And I wouldn't recommend
this in the workplace
or at home as a way to get
along with your family,
but as an investing philosophy,
it's absolutely brilliant.
And if you look at the careers
of the world's greatest
investors, people like Graham
or Warren Buffett or Charlie
Munger, you very much see
this kind of mentality
at work-- people who
separate themselves
from the prevailing tides of
emotion in the marketplace.
When other people are euphoric,
they find that troubling.
When other people are miserable,
they find that exciting.
And the only way you can
do that is with this kind
of emotional detachment.
So thank you.
I would love to
take some questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, Jason.
This was fantastic.
Folks, if you have questions,
just raise your hand
and I'll pass on the mic.
JASON ZWEIG: Yes, I'll
take this one first.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
A great--
MALE SPEAKER: If you
don't mind me [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Very great, entertaining
presentation.
But one issue we have, I
think even other people here,
with the picking stocks
is that we don't really
believe that we can actually
pick stocks that are not
going to go out of business.
See, it's very great,
like you were saying.
So where is the stock that I
know for sure, if it goes down,
I'm going to buy more?
Even IBM is not
like that anymore.
Like, there's no blue
chips or nothing.
If we go to small
stocks-- it'd be
arrogant to believe
that we can investigate
their annual reports,
their management.
They could be lying
in their reports.
So that's why, I guess,
maybe we should just
declare ourselves
defensive investors
and go with the index, because
you know the index's not
going to go to 0, right?
JASON ZWEIG: So we hope.
AUDIENCE: But if you can
say, maybe if you know,
which were the stocks
that maybe the large gaps
that we know that
Benjamin Graham used
to invest his core portfolio.
Was it, like, the
standard [INAUDIBLE]
or whatever it was at that time?
And kind of what you think
could be equivalent this time.
JASON ZWEIG: Well,
thank you for that.
And I think you largely
answered your own question.
I think the critical
factor for everyone
is to be well calibrated.
You need to know about
yourself-- how defensive
or how enterprising
am I prepared to be?
And how qualified do I feel
to become enterprising?
If you're not
comfortable with it,
or you've done a
reasonable analysis
and you can't get comfortable
that you could ever
assess the probabilities, then
you should stay defensive.
Now, being defensive
in Graham's terms
doesn't mean that your
portfolio should all be cash.
It just means you're
not going to analyze
individual securities.
You could put all your money
in stocks if you wanted to,
and putting it in index funds is
a perfectly defensible choice,
and a classic defensive choice.
I would add one
thing, I think, which
is that both Warren Buffett and
Charlie Munger, his partner,
have often talked about
the importance of combining
patience with what Charlie
Munger likes to call gumption--
you know, extreme determination
at the right moment.
And if you have the
sort of temperament
where, in a period like
the fourth quarter of 2008
or the first quarter
of 2009, you can say,
I don't think the world
is coming to an end.
I think financial
assets are cheap.
I'm going to add more.
So one way you can
be enterprising
is you could be enterprising
with a defensive portfolio.
You could say, the
next time there's
a financial crisis or a crash,
and there will be one probably
sooner rather than later--
although I have no idea when.
But the next time there's a
market panic, you could say,
I'm going to add a
substantial amount of money
to my portfolio.
Now, you don't have to do that.
And the next crash might
be the final crash,
and it might turn out
not to be a good idea.
But if history is
any guide, people
who take that step in
times of extreme disruption
tend to do very well
in the long run.
I think we had
another question here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you
for coming today, Jason.
Just had a question.
Who do you think are the
Benjamin Grahams and Warren
Buffetts of the 21st century?
Your top three candidates
in your opinion.
JASON ZWEIG: Oh boy.
I'm not sure I want to go on
record with that, actually.
AUDIENCE: Stop the recording.
JASON ZWEIG: I don't know that
that would make a difference.
I think it's really
important to be
humble about anybody's
ability to identify
skilled managers in advance.
And there certainly are
plenty of people out there
who are building great
track records right now.
But the amount of
statistical analysis
you have to do on
their performance
to have any confidence
that it isn't just luck
is really significant.
And in most cases, what
we have is reputation that
has gone largely unanalyzed.
And there are not
that many managers
whose records I've really
statistically analyzed yet,
because typically
by the time I get
ready to do that, their
performance has deteriorated.
So maybe talk to me afterwards.
But for now, I'm going to pass.
It' a really
interesting question,
but I'm going to pass
on that one for now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Jason,
for a great, insightful
presentation.
I have two-part
question, if it's OK.
One is a follow-up on the
question that was just asked.
If you were asked the same
question in the 70s and 80s,
would you have named
Buffett at that time,
or would you not have for
the exact same reason?
And if you would have,
why would you have?
JASON ZWEIG: Yeah.
I think in the 70s,
very few people
would have named Warren Buffett.
And there's a really
interesting, useful lesson
in that.
In many cases, just
given the standard
margins of
out-performance we tend
to observe in the
stock market where
someone who out-performs a
benchmark like the S&P 500
by 1 percentage point
a year compounded
is regarded as an
extraordinary achievement.
So over a period when
stocks are up 7% or 8%,
someone who earns 8% or
9% gets an enormous amount
of favorable attention.
It's a pretty narrow margin.
And then given the standard
deviation that is usually
embedded in a track
record like that,
often you need 50 to 80
years to have 95% confidence
that the person is
skillful and not lucky.
And at that point,
you've pretty much
dealt with a human lifespan--
your own and the money manager.
So there's kind of a
paradox that by the time
you can be confident
that the person is
really good at what
he or she is doing,
you're both about to die.
So I don't think most
people would have
identified Buffett in the 70s.
Quite a few did in the 1980s.
Carol Loomis, the great
financial journalist
at "Fortune" identified
him almost immediately
when she met him in the 60s.
Carol is a good friend of mine.
And some other
people did, as well.
But most people who've
invested in Berkshire Hathaway
arrived later.
The ones who made the
most money from Berkshire
are the ones who
identified him earliest.
AUDIENCE: So second question--
during your presentation
you referred to one
specific example
where investors had a
loss of principal Valeant.
When I look at the 13Fs, there's
quite a few renowned value
investors-- some
mutual funds that
go back all the way to the
70s that Buffett in the 70s
talked highly about,
some hedge funds,
some that actually worked
with Buffett in Geico.
So a lot of past successes.
What do you think,
in your opinion,
were errors of judgment?
You're obviously
looking in hindsight.
And then were there
lessons that one
could have learned
from, say, something
like investigative journalism
that maybe the investors didn't
apply to dig deeper?
JASON ZWEIG: Yeah.
I think the recent collapse
in the stock price of Valeant
Pharmaceuticals is going to
be a case study for years
to come in investing classes.
And I don't think we have
the full explanation yet
of what the cognitive
errors were,
the analytical errors
that professional money
managers made.
But I do think that what often
happens in situations like this
is-- and I'm speaking
in general terms
because I haven't done any
direct research on Valeant,
and I haven't spoken
directly about it with many
of the investors
you're referring,
so I'm just speculating.
But I think in
many cases, people
rely on the assurances
of management
and let qualitative factors
skew judgments that otherwise
would be quantitatively based.
And as an investor,
you always have
to be very sensitive
to retroactive
revisions of the reason
you own a security.
If originally you invested
based on quantitative measures,
and you now find
that you're using
qualitative justifications
for continuing to hold it,
then that is a red flag.
And certainly one
of the things I've
learned over the past
decade is the importance
of having a structured
decision process
and working off a checklist
or another template that
compels you to organize your
thinking and your rationale.
And it also makes it harder
for you to migrate away
from that over time.
And I think what we'll
learn with hindsight
is that many of these investors
bought the stock for one
set of reasons, and then
held it for a different set,
and that is always a
red flag in investing
as it is in a lot of
other things in life.
I mean, someone who married a
spouse for one set of reasons
and then stays with the
spouse for another set
is probably not likely to
have a very happy marriage.
And the same thing applies in
the financial world, I think.
Yes.
MALE SPEAKER:
Yeah, I noticed you
have a lot of comments
about marriage,
and I'm wondering if your wife
is going to be watching this.
We have time for
one last question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for a great talk.
JASON ZWEIG: Oh, you're welcome.
AUDIENCE: My question
is on the definition
of potential
conflict of interest.
In managing other
people's money,
do you see any
model that does not
have the potential of
conflict of interest?
And then follow-up on it is
what do you think about the VC
model, where they charge
management a fee, and and 20%
on the profit, I think?
JASON ZWEIG: Right.
Well, there are many groups in
the asset management business
who will tell you that they
have no conflict of interest.
In fact, I had a long email
dialogue about a year ago
with a financial
adviser who said to me,
my financial planning
practice is conflict-free.
I have no conflicts
of interest at all.
Just ask my clients.
And I tried to point out to him
that, in fact, no matter how
he charges, he can't help but
have conflicts of interest.
In fact, if he
didn't charge at all,
he would still have a conflict.
There's an irreducible
conflict in the fact
that someone who is
managing your money
is managing your money,
not his or her own.
And I don't think there's
any way to eliminate that.
The key is for the asset
manager and the client
to be on the same
page and to understand
where the conflicts are
and what the conflicts are.
So someone who is charging,
for example, 2 and 20
as a hedge fund might,
or some VC funds might,
has a clear incentive to raise
money, hang onto the money,
often take very
substantial risks.
And one of the things
you want to look for--
and again, this is just
a bit of general advice--
is as engineers, you're
very familiar with this sort
of approach.
You want to look at
the dispersion, right?
You want to say, well, who
out there is doing this
more cheaply, and
what does it look
like over at this end
of the distribution?
And then who's doing it
much more expensively,
and what does that look like?
And then where in that continuum
does this person or fund fall?
And am I comfortable with that?
Is there a better,
cheaper way to do it?
Or do the results seem to
be improved by higher fees?
I mean, I guess it's
theoretically possible.
But certainly what
you want to do
is you want to look at
the alternative ways
that you could be charged, and
ask yourself whether you're
more comfortable with one of
those other models of paying
fees rather than this one.
You don't have to pay 2 and
20 if you don't want to.
You might get stuck
doing it if you
like the people or
the process, but I
don't think you should accept
any fee structure as a given
or set in stone.
Increasingly there's
a diversity of ways
people will charge
to manage your money,
and I think, also, individual
investors tend to underestimate
their own negotiating power.
You should always get the form
80V, which is the standard SEC
disclosure that any
registered investment
adviser has to provide.
And often, when
you read the 80V,
you will see something
very interesting
that the person you met
with never mentioned.
Our fees are negotiable.
Very few asset managers
will volunteer that fact,
but by law, if
they may negotiate,
they must say they negotiate
in the disclosure form.
They don't have to
tell you directly,
but they do have to tell
you in the disclosure form.
And if you see it there,
you should bring it with you
when you meet with the person.
So I would just encourage you to
be as aggressive on that front
as you're comfortable
being because fees
are the primary determinant
of the difference
between good performance
and great performance.
And it's one thing that
you can control probably
much more so than you've
been led to believe.
So I would just encourage that.
MALE SPEAKER: Fantastic.
This was great.
And I really do hope that
when your book on marriage
is out, that you visit us again.
JASON ZWEIG: I'll bring
my wife, [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: All right,
thank you so much.
JASON ZWEIG: All
right, thank you.
My pleasure.